MIKE WOLFE: All right Rod, how's
Chicago suburbs treating ya?
MIKE WOLFE: Oh, man, Australia.
This is a guy that's an
expert with Rolls Royce.
He's going to tell us
the value, flat out.
There is not going
to be any guessing.
MIKE WOLFE: OK
Oh.
Self-driving.
Never owned a
chauffeur-driven car.
No.
So how rare is it
for it to be over here?
Yeah.
Would someone pay $20?
MIKE WOLFE: Well, I very much
appreciate you calling us back.
FRANK FRITZ: Thanks, Rod.
Appreciate you, Rod.
Bye bye.
MAN: Thank you.
- Thank you.
OK.
Well that was educational.
Yes.
MIKE WOLFE: He's saying that if
you have a car of this caliber
and want to take it to the
finish line, doing it right,
it would cost that
type of money.
You start talking museum-quality
restoration, concourse,
the elegance, Amelia Island,
all of that kind of stuff,
Pebble Beach--
no.
This ain't their car.
It's going to cost
too much money.
So I'm wondering if there's a
guy out there that would want
it presentable, but not
want it to the caliber
that he's speaking about.
Right.
MIKE WOLFE: If somebody doesn't
want to restore the car,
they just want to clean
the raccoon poop out of it
and get it running and drive
around go, check out my Rolls
Royce Rat Rod, this is it.
This is a working
man's Rolls Royce.
It seems like the number
might be, according to him,
maybe $20,000.
MIKE WOLFE: It's kind of
where I was leaning, $20,000.
So if it's $20,000, then I
can't be the guy for $20,000,
but I can be the
guy for $15,000.
If we could get
this car running,
so someone could
hear the engine--
Just at least it turn over.
I'm not talking
about driving it.
FRANK FRITZ: Right.
We could turn it over right now
and see if the engine's locked.
It'll turn over, I do believe.
Here, let's see.
Let's take a look here.
Yeah, it's turning over.
MIKE WOLFE: Good.
FRANK FRITZ: Yeah, it's free.
Well there you go.
You guys are at $15,000.
I'm at $20,000.
We split the
difference at $17,500.
The family's at the point
where we love the car,
but at the same time, we
have nowhere to store it
and we can't leave it here.
Yeah, but see the
thing is for me,
it doesn't make sense for
me to to buy it at $17,500.
I get it back to
make $2,000 bucks,
then I'm in the same
position you are because it's
taking up room as well.
How about $16,000?
Look at that face.
How could I say no to $16,000?
Are you kidding me?
Do you want me to pay $16,000?
Yeah.
When Marlene looks
up at me, and says,
would you do $16,00,
who could say no to her?
Can we hug instead of shake?
- Sure.
All right.
FRANK FRITZ: There you go.
- Thank you.
- OK, thanks.
Thank you.
Appreciate you.
Marlene, is either the
sweetest woman alive
or the best negotiator in Ohio.
Either way, I paid $16,000
and we have ourselves
a Rat Rod Rolls Royce.
All right, here we go.
I think she saw a lot
of her husband's passion
in the way we were
appreciating these items.
Thank you very much.
You didn't have to
help us do this.
And that made her proud
of what her and David
were able to accomplish.
They saved all of
these things together.
All righty.
- Appreciate you, my friend.
FRANK FRITZ: Thanks
for calling us, guys.
Appreciate it.
- Glad y'all could make it.
FRANK FRITZ: Thanks for the
[inaudible],, sweetheart.
Oh, yeah.
Sure.
FRANK FRITZ: I'll think of
you every time I [inaudible]..
- OK.
- So sweet.
Thank you so much.
WOMAN: I used to think
I would be really
sad about seeing the things go.
But the thought of having
somebody else enjoy it like we
enjoyed it makes
it a lot easier.
FRANK FRITZ: Good too see you.
Sweet pickings!
[horn]
See y'all later.
Take care!